okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to how to get past
rejection
by
angry picnic before i start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell today i'm going
to be reacting with my little pupper um
and if you guys have watched two or more
of my videos and you do not subscribe me
and you have beef you already know go
follow my instagram just dot pearly
things just dot pearly thanks
[Music]
after multiple attempts of trying to
find girls to reject us we have finally
found a handful of ladies that made us
work for their phone numbers i'm cody
strong from angry picnic here with that
was epic and this is how to get past
rejection
can you tell the viewers like how to
come how how to come back from rejection
or what to say after a girl says okay i
know nobody asks for my opinion but i'm
going to give it to you
if a girl rejects you it is all about
how you respond it is not about you
getting rejected
and i was talking about this with my
friend gabby how
we have been like madly in love with a
guy that we rejected initially and it
was all because he did not get butt hurt
and was like oh no you rejected me
that's giving us all the power and
saying our opinion matters like if
you're just confident and like act like
her opinion doesn't matter because it
doesn't i'm one girl and you have no
idea why i rejected you you have no idea
it could be because
like i'm still you know it could because
she's not over her ex it could be
because she's
i don't know like
just talking to someone that she's
really interested like you have no idea
why
and it doesn't mean you're a plan b
either it just
like sometimes the timing is just off
sorry okay i have a boyfriend you give
up well give me 15 seconds because i'm
actually going the other way 15 seconds
right now
right here okay
170 oh my gosh so now i'm at 190. thank
you so much for the donations
190
190 190. oh my gosh 195. thank you guys
thank you so much
oh my gosh because my goal is 500 so i'm
at 195 out of the 500 sound board
gorgeous i'm gorgeous uh-huh so we just
need to wrap this up i get your number
we go on a beautiful date later oh you
see do you see how he kept going
like he kept going
and he was just like what like whatever
beautiful day later so a lot of people
tell us that they have boyfriends and
then we and then we persist and then get
the number anyways
so do they do it because they feel bad
some girls might yeah some girls might
be like oh he's actually like and here's
another thing sometimes we're not
attracted to you like at first but
sometimes it's something when a guy
talks and he shows like he's confident
and charismatic like
i'm telling you i have been like the guy
that i was like obsessed with in college
i really didn't know if i liked him at
first
and
yeah like i'm telling you i'm telling
you guys i know the manosphere says oh
she looks at you as a plan b
oh she doesn't have that genuine desire
i am telling you i'm telling you
i have had genuine desire
for a guy that i was like no at first
and it's all because of how he responded
he didn't get oh no like
okay
trying
i'll give you that number i might have a
boyfriend in a different state
yeah well
i might be gay you might be gay but you
know these are just things that we might
have oh gosh so we don't have to worry
about him
do you see he didn't care he did not
care he was like okay so
and
what just
worry about right now in the moment
okay what's your number eight one six
eight one six eight seven two off the
top of your head is there any advice 210
210 dollars
oh my gosh thank you guys
thank you so much oh my gosh this is
making my day i'm gonna cry
i am going to cry
and being i'm gonna cry thank you um and
being funny also helps like if you guys
take a rejection and turn it into a joke
oh my gosh
you can give that all um no pickup lines
not like some stupid pickup
oh my gosh
oh my gosh
is that 220 or 230 i just lost count i
just lost can't wait i was at 150 at the
beginning of this live i was at 150 for
the sound board
and then
170 180 90
2 15 2 25 2 35
oh my god thank you guys so much
thank you
don't do that if you just like came up
and we're like hey like um i think
you're kind of cute like would you mind
like going to get lunch with me
sometimes compliments but did i stop
going live for a second i'm still live
right
okay i'm still live i just want to make
sure
not to
not something like super like sexual
yeah sexual that that we get what's your
name charlotte charlotte my swan nice to
meet you you're hot we should uh
we should meet up sometime and make out
oh um it's very forward
i actually have a boyfriend i'm sorry
i was being sarcastic but uh oh okay
i was hoping i mean oh you were hoping i
was being serious no it's hoping that
you're being so close
yeah do you see how he's like bantering
with her we love a good banter a good
banter makes us fall in love i swear to
god i swear to god
how about the coffee
do you have a boyfriend i mean
the coffee is fine
okay
um sure
seven eight five
thank you so much i don't know what dkk
is i don't know what the conversion is
hold on let me let me
let me convert it so i can cuz i'm at
235
um
dkk to
um
also if you want to send a donation to
my paypal it's hannah h-a-n-n-a-h
pearl p-e-a-r-l davis d-a-v-i-s
gmail.com
okay to dollars
um
conversion
calculator sorry i know i'm ruining this
this is going to be a tough
um
so us dollars is what okay so that's
maybe like 235
we'll just guess so like that's a third
so it's like five bucks so 240. okay
thank you thank you so much 240 240
thank you
um
500 is the goal to get the sound board
okay
7.5 confidence is key like if a guy came
if a guy came out to me it was like oh
hey but if god was like hey how are you
doing like you look really pretty today
and they had confidence i'd be more like
that but to them don't you get told
you're pretty like by every guy like
isn't that like boring to hear
no not in person like we don't we don't
get approached in person as much as you
guys think i look homeless half the time
so it's my own damn fault but so okay i
mean a girl might not say like oh thank
you like that really made my day but on
the inside they're probably thinking
like oh my gosh she thinks i'm pretty
you're gorgeous thanks what how do you
exist
wait wait wait i have to talk to you
what's your name marissa i'm hi i'm cody
nice to meet you all right 15 seconds
and that's a good way i learned this in
sales so how he said like 15 seconds
because when you talk to us
i'm nervous because i'm like oh my god
is this man gonna bother me and like not
leave me alone like that's that's what
we're thinking okay so if you come up
just and say hey hey just really quick i
think you're pretty let's go on a date
something like that
yeah you're 15 seconds try not to seem
like you're coming on just try to like
relate to them so like try to like not
even act like you're picking them up for
them yes and go and find out about them
your name's teresa yes what is that the
crap too okay
this is perfect because i want to buy
you a frappuccino later
as a date let's take you at starbucks
classic coffee date i bought you
frappuccino
classic store you fall in love with me
so simple yeah i don't know if i have
time anytime soon i'm busy okay
roll you know we'll figure that out like
i'll text you and we'll figure out a
time
because this could be magical
let's not feed around the bush it could
be magical i don't know
me neither so let's figure it out i'll
get your number i'll text you
and then you'll decide whether or not
i'm like the perfect manner okay
okay
uh what's your number um
seven six six most girls just one oh and
this is a comment you're nervous in 2022
try being a guy and having to deal with
me too yeah guys bro there's always
going to be obstacles women are not easy
to get like if they're easy to get there
wouldn't be thousands and thousands of
like
dollars put into like courses and [ __ ]
like that wouldn't exist
but but [ __ ] is hard okay
so that's gonna be an obstacle yeah
but
i saw this guy where this feminist was
like coming up to him and being like why
are you asking women questions
on the street and he literally just
called her pretty and he's like
and she was completely disarmed like you
can't react to the girls that are like
crazy
because if you react you are giving them
the power
you and i know it's hard i worked in
sales sometimes i wanted to die
because i would get rejected so much and
it was really hard but i'm telling you i
wanna feel like someone's just trying to
talk to them and not hit on them you
know i feel like i'm more attracted to
someone who's just trying to be my
friend your boyfriend doesn't let you
have friends
katie come on i'm really planted
katie
you're gonna shut me down like that okay
i get your number i text you
and if you don't
if you don't respond then i don't i
don't text again okay okay
what's your what's your number seven two
oh seven two
he
she's mad he didn't approach her look at
her her arms are crossed
is offering a coffee date creepy or is
that something that you'd like
back in the day people got asked out to
like dinners and stuff like that like
guys have gotten so cheap like now it's
just coffee you don't even get to whine
and dine me like
i'd rather go out to dinner like now
it's just coffee excuse me ladies but i
was just wondering if you all three
would like to join me as i fine dine and
drink some wine like all three of us on
one date yeah
um i don't think so okay well to be
honest i just wanted her to go on a date
with me but like
i figured that she'd probably say no
because she's with all her friends and
i'd rather like hang out with her with
all three of you than not at all so all
right well i think i could just get your
number probably not i'm really busy okay
well i'm sorry
just give me one chance and that's all i
need and trust me you're going to be
like whoa this was a phenomenal date
yeah okay all right 9.9 did you see
do you see how he responded
he wasn't whiny he wasn't like oh please
or like he didn't he didn't go backwards
and like
like like his body language was like
okay whatever like he he acted like he
didn't even hear her
and his tonality your tonality is so
important
your tonality is so important like if
you
and it's hard and i noticed this when i
was in sales like if someone would say
no and i just said oh okay well why is
that or like i was just like
i just kept asking questions
um like people
people would be a lot more receptive
than if i was like oh
okay
like that's
i don't know then you kind of seem like
a [ __ ]
two one two that's one thing girls are
just super weird
okay
and anything else you'd like to say
no i think that's pretty much it thank
you for watching the video make sure to
head on over to that was epic's channel
to check out the video we did together
don't forget to subscribe and i'll see
you next time
yeah how many this guy's gotta have a
lot of subs 2.7 million okay guys
i don't even know if i'm gonna be able
to clip this because i i got so excited
about donations but
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
the way you're gonna be notified of my
daily videos and i will talk to you guys
next time